bien mes chers collègues membres de la
commission spéciale nous sommes réunis
avec nos rapporteurs Patrick chaise et
Loïc Hervé pour accueillir ensemble
monsieur Jean-Philippe Lecouf
directement exécutif adjoint des
opérations de repos merci Monsieur le
Directeur d'être en lien avec notre
commission pour cette audition vous êtes
à La Haye j'imagine
oui madame la Présidente bonjour bonjour
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
membres du Sénat et de la commission
spéciale oui je suis en direct de La
Haye de l'état-major de Europe voilà un
site que j'ai eu le plaisir de visiter
il y a quelques mois fortement
impressionné par le travail extrêmement
sérieux qui s'y exercé alors la robe
Europole le rappeler l'Agence européenne
de police criminelle qui est de la
coordination de la lutte contre les
stupéfiants la pédocriminalité ou encore
le terrorisme avec les rapporteurs si
nous avons souhaité vous entendre de
dans le cadre de ces travaux de notre
commission spéciale c'est bien pour
marquer la dimension internationale de
ces délits et l'indispensable
coordination bien entendu qui doit être
réalisé au niveau européen pour les
contenir d'autant que
un texte qui va nous occuper début
juillet dans dans l'hémicycle ni plus ni
moi l'application de règlement européen
sur les services nués numériques et
notamment sur le RSN ou DSA qui établit
de manière explicite le rôle de RuPaul
comme signaler de confiance donc
d'ailleurs le statut est prévu à
l'article 22 du règlement il contraint
les plateformes à traiter par priorité
vos signalements dans le cas de la
prévention d'une infraction pénale
l'article 18 par ailleurs établit que si
le fournisseur d'accès auprès duquel un
signalement est opéré
s'il ne peut pas identifier avec
certitude le pays concerné il en informe
immédiatement européenne
au-delà donc de ces ajouts utiles nous
serons très attentifs monsieur le
directeur à votre analyse de ce que l'on
pourrait qualifier de criminalité
numérique
donc elle mesure les plateformes avec
lesquelles vous travaillez au quotidien
vous semble-t-elle ou sont-elles
coopératives pensez-vous que les
nouvelles obligations que le règlement
va leur imposer seront de nature à mieux
appréhender les comportements délictueux
qui peuvent commencer en ligne et
déborder bien entendu dans la vie réelle
donc je vous propose de vous donner la
parole pour une dizaine de minutes et
bien entendu après je passerai la parole
à nos rapporteurs et à l'ensemble des
collègues ici présent particulièrement
intéressé à cet aspect du texte de loi
qui nous occupe voilà Monsieur le
Directeur je vous souhaite immédiatement
la parole
merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les membres du de la
commission spéciale je suis très honoré
de pouvoir m'exprimer aujourd'hui devant
vous et vous donner un point de vue au
nom de Paul
sur le travail législatif que vous êtes
en train de défectuer
tous à quel point les développements
technologiques offrent de multiples
opportunités positives pour la majorité
d'entre eux mais aussi combien la
numérisation représente un puissant
catalyseur pour les criminels donc c'est
pourquoi le traitement des preuves
électroniques ou des contenus criminels
en ligne sont devenus en fait des tâches
quotidiennes et essentielles pour tous
les services répressifs au sein de
l'Union européenne et donc pour Europe 1
la criminalité en ligne évolue
rapidement
les services répressifs se heurtent
seurent et les services d'investigation
sortent tout à fait régulièrement à de
nouveaux défis et il est vrai que le
législateur peine à suivre leur rythme
effréné des développements
technologiques
mais ceci dit le Règlement sur les
services numériques ou DSA et le
bienvenu ainsi que le travail que fait
votre commission pour pouvoir justement
faire face à ces défis qui évoluent sans
cesse le caractère par ailleurs
international des services mais aussi
des crimes numériques
limites et c'est important de le
souligner les approches exclusivement
nationales et plaid pour des approches
internationales européennes d'abord pour
ce qui nous concerne
et
international parce que on a évidemment
plus de d'impact de puissance je voulais
comme comme j'en avais discuté
un petit peu avec le secrétaire de votre
commission vous évoquez en fait un petit
état des lieux assez rapide de la menace
puisque je veux laisser de la place pour
vos questions et puis le soutien de
RuPaul et quelques propos conclusifs
pour les menaces numériques les
principales menaces qu'on voit au niveau
de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui sont les suivantes d'abord
et en tête on place l'abus les abus et
les exploitation sexuelle des enfants
ces abus et cette exploitation sexuelle
des enfants reste une préoccupation
majeure pour les services répressifs car
il s'agit d'une priorité essentielle
puisque on s'attaque à des personnes
vulnérables dans leur dans leur
nationalité
depuis la pandémie nous avons constaté
une explosion de de ces de ces affaires
en particulier une augmentation de de
contenu dit autoproduit c'est à dire des
jeunes qui sont amenés par des
discussions
à dévoiler
des parties de leur intimité etc je
voulais faire ici peut-être un petit une
petite incise si vous permettez ou une
parenthèse qui me paraît importante
puisque
à Europole on est attaché à à
évacuer le mot je dirais de
pédopornographie
pourquoi parce que la pornographie n'est
pas une infraction en soi
c'est ça peut être condamnable
moralement etc mais ça n'est en tout cas
pas une infraction
alors que exploiter sexuellement des
enfants
les Violets
à tenter à leur pudeur et plus que c'est
un crime et quand on utilise le mot de
pédopornographie on affaiblit et on crée
une sorte de confusion entre la
pornographie et ce que sont les abus et
les exploitations sexuelles des enfants
qui sont des crimes et donc vous ne
m'entendrez pas parler de
pédopornographie ici mais à chaque fois
d'exploitation sexuelle des enfants ou
d'abus sexuel sur les enfants c'est un
c'est une utilisation du vocabulaire qui
nous paraît ici à Europe 1 absolument
importante à souligner donc pour ces
abus sexuels et tout ce matériel ces
contenus il existe un vaste marché qui
ne cesse de croître la gravité aussi des
infractions croit également
puisque avec le développement des moyens
technologiques on voit des infractions
nouvelles comme du live streaming sur de
viols d'enfants se développer c'est des
choses évidemment
terribles les délinquants dans ce
domaine sont d'ailleurs preuves de
connaissances techniques de plus
poussées
puisque ils ont évidemment conscience de
commettre des crimes particulièrement
abject il cherche à se dissimuler
évidemment de
passion
des services répressifs donc ils
utilisent massivement du chiffrement ils
essayent de cacher leur conversation de
cacher leurs échanges etc
on constate aussi une augmentation de la
monétisation de ces contenus de ces
contenus d'abus et d'exploitation
sexuelle des enfants y compris en direct
je l'évoquais et certaines plateformes
ne parviennent pas à empêcher l'accès
des mineurs qui peuvent s'inscrire sur
les plateformes
en utilisant soit des VPN soit de
fausses pièces d'identité etc pour
poster eux-mêmes des vidéos explicites
deuxième type de menace liées au monde
numérique évidemment les cyberattaques
c'est pas l'essentiel de votre sujet
aujourd'hui mais ça représente une une
menace qui s'est accrue en terme
d'attaque on en a tous entendu parler
sur les hôpitaux des collectivités
territoriales les entreprises etc nombre
qui augmente sophistication des attaques
par logiciellement malveillant rend son
logiciel piratage attaque par déni de
service qu'on a pu voir c'est une de nos
préoccupations principales et souligne
que cette année pour la première fois
deux cybercriminels liés à un certain
nombre de cyberata qui ont été inscrits
sur la liste des personnes les plus
recherchées par l'Union européenne une
liste queueropole tient ce qui montre
que ça monte
une fraude aussi massive c'est la fraude
en ligne
qui en particulier la fraude au paiement
en ligne et les cyber escroquerie qui
sont parmi des infractions criminelles
les plus établies et qui peuvent toucher
en masse nos concitoyens
[Musique]
le contenu des contenus terroristes en
ligne qui doivent faire l'objet sont une
menace particulièrement importante liées
au développement des espaces numériques
la semaine dernière on repole a publié
son rapport annuel sur le terrorisme et
l'extrémisme dans l'Union européenne ce
qu'on appelle entre nous le tissac teat
2023 il montre que la menace terroriste
reste très importante et que internet
représente un outil essentiel pour
l'échange de contenu liés au terrorisme
et aussi la diffusion d'idéologie
extrémiste qui peuvent conduire au
terrorisme on peut penser en particulier
à la radicalisation en ligne ou alors au
recrutement de jeunes vulnérables par
des organisations terroristes ou
extrémistes que ce soit en ligne sur les
plateformes ou même par l'intermédiaire
de plateforme de jeux
en ligne et
donc
sur vus panorama rapide des menaces
criminelles liées au numérique Europole
se félicite évidemment des actions
récentes des législateurs de l'Union
européenne pour légiférer dans l'espace
numérique et notamment
sur deux textes qui nous paraissent
essentiels le Règlement sur les contenus
terroristes en ligne qu'on appelle le
TCO entre nous terroriste canton online
et le Règlement sur les services
numériques le RSN ou DSA ces textes
législatifs sont novateurs dans la
mesure où il constitue une première
tentative de niveau important régional
européenne de s'attaquer à la diffusion
de contenu illicite en ligne à grande
échelle en faisant peser des obligateurs
des obligations pardon sur les
diffuseurs et ça nous paraît un point
tout à fait important et essentiel et
compte tenu de la nature mondiale des
services global comme on dit en anglais
des services et des et donc des délits
numériques cette approche régionale
importante par l'Union européenne
relayée évidemment par ces États membres
peut avoir un impact réel et éviter des
déplacements d'une plateforme à l'autre
ou d'un pays à l'autre puisque l'impact
sera mondial et ce ces textes
contiennent également des mesures
dissuasives très importantes par rapport
à ces grandes diffuseurs
je vous propose maintenant d'évoquer le
soutien qui apporte Europole aux États
membres dans la lutte contre ces menaces
numériques je me concentrerai sur les
domaines qui sont au cœur du travail de
votre commission cette nuit c'est à dire
les contenus illégaux en ligne
d'abord peut-être pour évoquer les
signalements et le retrait des contenus
terroristes en ligne en 2015 Europole a
créé une unité de signalement sur
Internet
qui s'appelle le iru pour internet
référent
cette unité de travail en étroite
collaboration avec les autorités
compétentes des États membres de l'Union
européenne et aussi avec les
fournisseurs de services d'hébergement
et ce afin d'entraver la diffusion de
contenu terroristes sur Internet on
travaille typiquement avec Pharos qui
est l'un de nos grands partenaires
l'une des tâches principales de cette
internet référent unit iru c'est et de
ses partenaires nationaux chargés
d'appliquer de l'application de la loi
comme comme farros ça consiste à
signaler les contenus terroristes en
particulier au fournisseur de services
afin qu'il les évalue volontairement et
sur la base de leurs conditions de
service propre à chaque entreprise et
qu'il les supprime qui je dirais cela
leur scier mais la décision reste
l'heure depuis la création de cette de
cette irrue l'unité a détecté des
terroristes c'est important de le
souligner sur plus de 430 plateformes en
ligne 430
donc mais j'y reviendrai tout ça est
fait volontairement
les cyberattaques pardon
cette approche donc
effondrée sur la bonne volonté des
entreprises elle a donné de très bons
résultats en limitant la disponibilité
de contenu terroristes en ligne en
particulier sur les plateformes médias
sociaux grand public il existe cependant
de grandes différences dans la manière
dont les entreprises
réagissent et s'engage avec les
autorités nationales compétentes pour
modérer ces contenus et on peut
constater que la modération proactive
des contenus appliqués par les
entreprises et je dirais extrêmement
différente et qu'elle pousse donc les
réseaux terroristes à diffuser leur
contenu sur des plateformes dont les
politiques internes peuvent être plus ou
moins
contraignantes pour eux et c'est là où
évidemment dans ce contexte le lieu a
adopté a décidé d'adopter le Règlement
sur les contenus terroristes en ligne en
2021 en particulier
suite à l'attentat terroriste et à
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty en France
qui avait vu la diffusion de contenu
particulièrement intolérable sur les
réseaux et de renforcer les efforts de
répression contre ces contenus puisque
ce règlement va bien au-delà d'une
approche volontaire
des retraites puisque les retraits sont
obligatoires à partir du moment où les
fournisseurs de services
ont été en juin par les autorités
nationales de retirer ses services et
autres bénéfices de ce règlement c'est
qu'il permet de coordonner les actions
de retrait entre les différentes
autorités compétentes des États membres
en évitant ainsi
des publications
l'unité Pharos pouvant travailler sur un
dossier sur lequel est en train de
travailler en même temps l'unité
italienne l'unité allemande etc passant
par un point d'accès unique comme repole
on limite c'est duplications c'est un
élément extrêmement important donc le
règlement impose vous le savez au
fournisseurs de services d'hébergement
de retirer les contenus terroristes en
ligne dans l'heure qui suit la réception
d'un ordre de retrait exige également de
ces plateformes qu'elle soit plus active
dans la détection des contenus
terroristes
le évidemment
le règlement précise clairement ce sont
les autorités nationales
et non les fournisseurs de services en
ligne qui ont le dernier mot en matière
de modération de ces contenus
terroristes et c'est là où on passe
d'une approche à une approche contrainte
ceci dit
il convient aussi de dire que on doit
continuer une approche partenariale avec
ces plateformes et que l'ordre de
retrait d'un contenu terroriste doit
rester si on le peut et dans la majorité
des cas
une arme de dissuasion quand on n'a pas
réussi à faire entendre raison par le
référencement avec aux plateformes en
question
[Musique]
c'est ce mandat en fait le mandat
d'Europe prévoit que RuPaul puisse
soutenir les États membres dans tous les
signalements sur Internet dans tous les
domaines de compétences de l'agence donc
nous travaillons
très très
excusez-moi j'ai dû sauter une une page
de mon
discours sur ça que je retrouvais plus
le fil de mon expos
le je disais oui que l'expérience de
RuPaul en matière de modération de ces
contenus terroristes et et le rôle qui
lui a été donné d'interface en fait
entre les autorités nationales et les
plateformes au niveau européen la place
dans une position très favorable pour
exercer ce mandat nous avons créé une
plateforme
qui s'appelle Percy pour plateforme
européenne des retraites des contenus
illégaux sur internet pour une fois la
chronique est en français
donc ce qui contrôle de la France
d'ailleurs dans cette affaire cette
plateforme que nous allons lancer dans
quelques jours est un système unique et
collaboratif pour la transmission des
signalements et des ordres de retrait
par les autorités compétentes dans tous
les États membres de l'UE vers les tous
les fournisseurs qui ont obligation de
symmatriculer auprès d'un des pays de
l'Union européenne beaucoup sont
immatriculés auprès de l'Irlande comme
comme vous le savez Percy va favoriser
les échanges d'information avec ces
fournisseurs de services d'hébergement
mais il facilite aussi la coopération et
la coordination des efforts entre les
différentes autorités compétentes pour
lutter contre ces contenus terroristes
en ligne et éviter les duplications
c'est ce que j'expliquais un petit peu
tout à l'heure en parlant de Pharo c'est
de ces équivalents européens
persil contribue ainsi à une application
harmonisée du règlement TCO dans les 27
États membres
je j'ai déjà souligné mais je prends
l'occasion de ce travail pour souligner
que les relations établies avec la
plateforme française avec Pharos sont
absolument
remarquables et excellente c'est Faro
c'est un de nos partenaires les plus
proches les plus actifs les plus anciens
et tous les États membres y compris
Pharo sont été consultés évidemment dans
la création et le développement de cette
plateforme Percy
alors maintenant
parlons un petit peu du Règlement sur
les services numériques du DSA et le
signalement et les retraits des contenus
illicites dans le cadre de ce règlement
donc alors que le règlement TCOs
concentrait uniquement sur les contenus
terroristes le Règlement sur les
services numériques comme vous le savez
adopter en 2022 prévoit de manière plus
générale la modération de tous les
contenus en
comme pour le réglement TCO
Europole pourrait aider les États
membres à appliquer ces dispositions
pertinentes de la Loi sur les services
numériques afin d'optimiser son impact
sur les mesures répressives le mandat
d'Europe prévoit en effet que Europole
puisse soutenir les États membres pour
les signalements sur Internet dans tous
les domaines de compétences de l'agence
c'est-à-dire dans tous les domaines
criminels à cet égard nous avons engagé
des premières discussions avec la
Commission en particulier Connect qui
sera chargé de l'application
du DSA de façon à voir comment nous
pouvons offrir une expertise et
peut-être une infrastructure
équivalente à celle développée pour la
mise en oeuvre du règlement TCO pour le
DSA on pense en effet ici que notre
outil technique persi on l'a conçu en
tout cas avec une vision qui n'était pas
étroitement
des terroristes mais on s'est dit que ça
pourrait servir à d'autres évidemment
infractions en ligne
notre but principal étant d'éviter les
doublons et une multiplication de
travail au sein des 27 alors que un seul
peut tirer parti de déstructures
existantes pour modérer de façon
centralisée les contenus en ligne je
reviens enfin sur sur les abus à
l'exploitation sexuelle des enfants
pour vous dire que
ça constitue évidemment un autre domaine
où les contenus illégaux en ligne
sur lequel Europole joue un rôle
important pourrait
avoir des conséquences en matière
d'application évidemment du Règlement
sur les services numériques on dispose
d'une équipe spécialisée depuis plus de
20 ans dédié à la lutte contre
l'exploitation et les abus sexuels des
enfants en ligne une équipe qu'on
appelle la paix pour analyse project
twins
comme jumeau ces experts en fait
soutiennent les forces de l'ordre
d'aimant des États membres de l'Union
européenne 24 heures sur 24 dans
l'exploitation et les abus sexuels des
enfants cette équipe par exemple en 2022
a coordonné 93 enquêtes internationales
sur ces contenus
d'abus et d'exploitation sexuelle des
enfants
dans l'une de ces enquêtes pour vous
donner une idée
on visait une dizaine de milliers de
comptes qui étaient
intéressés qui possède et qui
partageaient des contenus
illicites autour de cette courte cette
seule opération 146 enfants ont pu être
identifiés dans le monde et des
informations étaient envoyées au service
de police ces différents États membres
13 pays sur trois continents étaient
impliqués c'est grâce en fait à la
coordination internationale des
activités d'enquête que ce grand nombre
de victimes et de suspects a pu être
identifié
en ce qui concerne plus spécifiquement
la modération du contenu
notre équipe twins facilite et également
la réception et la diffusion des
exploitations de signalement
d'exploitation sexuelle des enfants en
ligne en effet on a un accord avec les
entreprises qui sont basées aux
États-Unis qui signale à un organisme
américain qui s'appelle le National
Center for missing and exploitite
Shenron le nekmek comme on dit entre
nous tous les contenus suspects sont
transférés en fait par les plateformes à
cet organisme qui par le biais d'un de
nos partenaires américains nous transmet
ces contenus et servons à Europole de
points d'entrée unique pour 20 pays
européens
les autres étant couvert par une
transmission directe de ce nekmec vers
leurs autorités nationales et on fait
office de points central de diffusion ça
permet à Europole d'enrichir les
rapports du nekmek en particulier grâce
à notre base de données de contenu
illicite en ligne on a la plus grande la
deuxième plus grande base de données au
monde de de ces contenus
et ça permet dans de déclencher des
mesures d'enquête dans les États membres
en 2022 on a reçu analyser et diffuser
plus de 290 000 signalements de ce
nekmek ça représente à peu près
5600 signalements par semaine
ça montre aussi la pertinence d'avoir un
travail au niveau européen
en conclusion en fait ce que je voulais
vous dire avant de répondre à vos
questions
et j'espère que cet état des lieux a
permis de le clarifier trois choses
principales premièrement la criminalité
numérique évolue rapidement et la
technologie permet aux acteurs criminels
d'agir plus vite et mieux et souvent en
toute impunité en utilisant ou en
détournant les plateformes et les
services qui sont présents sur le marché
deuxièmement le pouvoir d'une
législation telle que le TCO ou le DSA
réside évidemment dans l'établissement
de règles efficace à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne et d'action corps
donnée entre les États membres pour
lutter contre cette criminalité
numérique c'est un pouvoir qui s'exerce
tant vis-à-vis des acteurs criminels que
des fournisseurs de services en ligne
dont la coopération avec les services
répressif est absolument essentiel au
succès de ces entreprises et la
dimension européenne permet d'avoir un
impact
important sur ces
partenaires privés qui sont d'une taille
mondiale
troisièmement Europole joue un rôle
central en aidant les États membres dans
leurs efforts de lutte contre la
criminalité numérique en général et
contre les contenus illégaux en ligne en
particulier la clé du succès pour nous
réside dans une coordination et une
coopération efficace entre tous les
États membres en évitant les doublons et
en s'appuyant sur des structures et une
expertise déjà existante pour modérer
ces contenus en ligne
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction et je suis prêt évidemment
à répondre à vos questions dans le cadre
de votre travail parlementaire
merci Monsieur le Directeur une longue
et précise introduction qui a déjà
permis je pense de répondre à quelques
questions qu'on se posait je passe la
parole à Loïc Hervé notre rapporteur sur
cette partie du texte pour compléter
donc les questions merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur merci
pour cette exposé et quelques questions
qui reviendront sur des choses que vous
avez déjà en partie développée d'abord
vous avez évoqué vos relations avec les
plateformes
de quelle nature sont-elles comment et
de quelle qualité sont-elles c'est à
dire que est-ce que vous estimez que les
plateformes notamment les plus grandes
d'entre elles sont à la hauteur des des
enjeux que qui sont qui sont ceux
qui ont des enjeux à la fois d'ordre
public de
et cette régulation là j'ai bien compris
qu'elle passait aussi par ce dialogue
que vous pouvez entretenir avec eux et
d'ailleurs que les autres autorités
publiques des états peuvent entretenir
mais qu'est-ce qui pourrait être assez
dégâts amélioré par ailleurs sur le DSA
qui est le texte qui nous intéresse
est-ce que vous estimez qu'il y a des
dimensions qui qui manquent ou des
choses qu'il faudrait compléter alors on
sera pas évidemment sur mesure de
compléter le règlement européen qui est
d'application directe en droit interne
en revanche sur l'application française
ça peut être l'occasion
aussi avec l'organisation que nous avons
des services de policiers de gendarmerie
l'occasion peut-être de faire passer un
certain nombre ou de messages ou
directement dans le dur de la loi les
évolutions importantes je prolonge en
disant que le DSA prévoit des règlements
des régulations importantes pour les
très grandes plateformes elles sont
elles sont 19 aucune des Françaises et
est-ce qu'à votre sens
la marge de manoeuvre des états pourrait
être utilisée pour peut-être concerné
davantage de plateformes encore que les
que celles qui ont 49 millions de
connexion nous avons
auditionné Madame la Commissaire
générale Augereau de farose elle s'est
quitté de l'alourdissement qui pourrait
être généré par les procédures
européennes
pour notamment procéder à des blocages
dit qu'on peut qualifier de de massif
d'un certain nombre de contenus
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire de ce de ce risque
sachant que nous on essaye de la même
manière de simplifier sur un certain
nombre de de choses en passant plutôt
par la voie administrative que par la
voie judiciaire pour essayer d'être plus
plus efficace plus efficient et plus
rapide
et tout en préservant évidemment la
question proprement dite des libertés
individuelles mais il y a quand même une
question de d'urgence sur un certain
nombre de d'interventions que nous avons
constaté qui nous est en tout cas et qui
nous vraiment une exigence sociale
pouvez-vous peut-être détailler les
conséquences de l'adoption abréviation
d'un nouveau règlement visant à prévenir
à combattre les abus sexuels sur les
enfants vous en avez déjà parlé mais
qu'est-ce que vous pourrez revenir un
peu sur son le calendrier d'adoption de
président
déjà demandé à Monsieur le Directeur à
savoir est-ce que vous pensez que le DSA
dans sa forme actuelle telle que nous
avons l'appliquer en tout cas le texte
de loi qui va nous être soumis peut-être
complété par quelques dispositions qui
émaneraient en fait par anticipation du
projet de règlement puisqu'on a vu que
sur certains autres aspects du texte on
anticipe par exemple le Data qui est en
cours de négociation encore à Bruxelles
est-ce que en sommes il y a des
dispositions prévues dans le règlement
visant à lutter et après les abusifs sur
les enfants qui pourraient presque
complémentaires et transmis par
antipathie enfin appliqué par
anticipation excuse-moi Loïc c'était
juste
par ailleurs les auditions ont permis de
mettre en évidence un problème lié à
l'équilibre entre la protection des
données personnelles d'une part elle est
nécessités de la lutte contre la
criminalité en ligne comment est-ce que
RuPaul
procède-t-il pour identifier les auteurs
d'infraction et dans quelle mesure les
outils actuels dépendent-ils des
plateformes et non des informations
collectées par les services en quête des
états c'est ça c'est une des questions
sur lesquelles évidemment j'aimerais que
vous puissiez revenir dernière
dernière question alors on va essayer de
faire un autre s'il est mon collègue
Cora pour toi et la présidente sont
d'accord de votre réflexion sur la le
qualificatif de
pédopornographique il y avait déjà
d'autres d'autres
personnes auditionnées qui nous en ont
fait part c'est vrai que c'est un thème
qui est ambigu mais
il a il a un seul mérite c'est qu'on
sait de quoi on parle
voilà il pose un problème conceptuel
mais on sait de quoi on parle c'est sûr
que il ne peut être remplacé que par une
périphrase et la périphrase en elle-même
elle elle elle pose d'autres difficultés
bref
le projet de loi risque de mettre si les
collègues évidemment le vote et que
c'est qu'il est promulguait ainsi met en
place une jonction pénale en cas de
défaut d'exécution d'une demande de
retrait d'un contenu
mettant en scène des enfants victimes de
d'action criminelles quel est votre
analyse sur cette disposition et vous la
capacité de dresser un premier bilan
d'une procédure analogue créée pour les
comptes du terrorisme par leur règlement
TCO est-ce que ce que vous pensez que
c'est le bon outil merci Monsieur le
Directeur bien j'espère monsieur le
directeur vous avez eu la possibilité de
noter les questions nombreuses de notre
collègue sinon elle reviendra dessus
donc je vous donne immédiatement la
parole pour les réponses
oui merci il y a juste la dernière
question que j'ai pas bien
saisi peut-être on la reposera tout à
l'heure peut-être voilà on va vous
laisser répondre au problème de
questions voilà donc je vais répondre au
première question sur la qualité des
des liens que nous entretenons avec les
différentes plateformes
[Musique]
écoutez globalement
c'est bien sont plutôt bons ce que les
grandes plateformes alors ils sont
inégaux ils sont plutôt bons mais on se
heurte quand même aux politiques
internes de chaque plateforme en matière
de référencement et de contenu jusqu'à
présent on a uniquement dans le TCO on a
pu mettre en oeuvre une douzaine de
demandes d'ordre de retrait
ce qui est pas énorme mais c'est dû au
fait que la plateforme qui va nous
servir à faire ça à Percy et pas encore
complètement en service on pense que ça
va augmenter
les relations sont plutôt de bonne
qualité je dirais
à ce stade
et elles sont basées quand même sur la
comme je le disais le caractère
volontaire des différentes plateformes
il peut y avoir des des différences
où c'est vraiment différent c'est sur la
proactivité et là puisque nous on
intervient la plupart du temps
en réactivité c'est à dire qu'un contenu
nous est signalé et à ce moment-là on va
se tourner vers la plateforme pour lui
dire ce contenu il faudrait regarder
l'heure en fonction de vos de vos
dispositions internes etc et en fonction
de ça retirez-le éventuellement
volontairement
dans ce cadre là la qualité des
relations est plutôt bonne ce qu'ils
apprécient je crois
sur europele c'est qu'ils ont un point
d'entrée unique et un élément de
discussion unique au lieu d'être obligé
parfois de discuter avec trois quatre
cinq dix
plateformes nationales ce qui leur pose
plus de difficultés et nous on a aussi
des points de contact bien identifiés
donc je dirais que la qualité est plutôt
bonne malgré tout on est tout à fait
preneur du fait que on est un instrument
coercitif dans la main l'ordre de
retrait pour faire de la pédagogie je
dirais et c'est un peu le sens j'y
reviendrai de ces outils à mon avis
y a-t-il des lacunes des points
améliorer dans le dans le DSA
ou le RSN je dirais que bon un des
sujets qu'on a c'est de réussir à faire
des textes qui soient un petit peu
technologiquement neutre
c'est-à-dire dont la pertinence puisse
se maintenir au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution des technologies et ça c'est
un véritable enjeu je crois que le DSA
il réussit en partie puisque le
développement de ces technologies est
rapide
il y a il restera sans doute des gap il
y a sûrement des choses qu'on n'a pas vu
il restera sûrement des choses à adapter
pour l'instant je dois dire que
et c'est ce que je soulignais ça nous
paraît assez effectivement à partir du
moment où on n'a pas une approche qui
est uniquement je dirais répressive
vis-à-vis des plateformes mais que on a
dans la main un outil répressif mais
quand même temps on continue
d'entretenir des partenariats pour que
volontairement ils puissent ils puissent
continuer à réguler je crois d'ailleurs
que ce matin
j'entendais sur les nouvelles françaises
que Elon Musk avait évoqué Twitter et le
fait qu'il allait se conformer
aux lois etc
sur les plateformes la question que vous
avez posée
je pense qu'il y a de la place
pour les les
les règlements enfin les lois nationales
pour réussir à imposer parce que comme
je vous ai dit on a détecté on a à peu
près nous un peu plus de 400 430
plateformes qu'on a identifié et comme
vous le mentionniez très justement
l'Union européenne va s'occuper des 19
plus grosses qu'on 45
millions d'utilisateurs et plus tout ce
qui est en dessous
ça mérite donc s'il est législations
nationales peuvent être adaptées de
façon à ce que
les les instruments coercitifs je dirais
du cas puisse s'appliquer à des
plateformes plus petites au sein de
chaque État membre et à condition
évidemment que les plateformes soient
hébergées sur le territoire de ces États
membres puisque tout est question de
juridiction ici
si on n'est pas dans une juridiction
française avec le risque qu'on déplace
la plateforme évidemment sur une
juridiction plus favorable et c'est bien
ce que le DSH cherché à éviter au niveau
européen se disant qu'une plateforme ne
pouvait pas se passer du marché européen
et qu'à partir de là à partir du moment
en tout cas ces grandes plateformes
qu'elle ne pouvait que avoir une
représentation
en France donc je pense que oui il y a
de la place pour réguler les plateformes
plus petites à partir de loi nationale
et en copiant en quelque sorte un petit
peu les les
je dirais le Règlement sur les services
numériques
[Musique]
le les blocages
de sites en fait et l'agourdissement des
procédures
j'entends l'argument il est vrai que bon
pour réussir à contraindre des
partenaires privés qui ont des services
juridiques très développés etc il faut
avoir les Rhin solides et préparer
effectivement des une documentation qui
en même temps assure le respect des
droits fondamentaux de la protection des
données personnelles etc et en même
temps soit efficace donc la procédure
peut parfois être jugée comme lourdes
après elle a un gros avantage c'est que
on évite de la dupliquer c'est à dire
que pourquoi
farose montrait un dossier sur une
plateforme qui a déjà été signalé par
les collègues allemands ou italien ou
espagnol et déjà interdite ou il y a eu
des retraits passés par l'outil
par les différents outils de de de
connexion donc je fais que le fait
d'organiser le travail un peu au niveau
européen pour éviter les duplications et
à mon avis un des moyens de de
de faire face je dirais ou de
contrepartie à cet alourdissement des
procédures j'envoie un autre aussi c'est
celui que j'évoquais que j'ai déjà
développé qui fait que cet outil doit
être un outil un petit peu de dernier
recours et l'idée c'est d'abord de
parler avec les plateformes pour que
volontairement elle retire les contenus
et si jamais ça ne marche pas en termes
de rétorsion entre guillemets ou de
pédagogie active on va dire
on leur envoie un ordre de retrait
sur le ce qu'on appelle entre nous le
CSA qu'on a trouvé en fait le moyen
d'éviter les périphrase pour éviter
pédopornographie on parle de Child
section la biose
matériaux Sam en anglais donc c'est
peut-être un moyen aussi d'avoir une
abréviation qui veut dire et sur le
nouveau règlement qui est en train
d'être discuté bon évidemment heureux
Paul n'est pas parti à la discussion
législative au niveau européen puisque
ça se passe évidemment entre le
Parlement et puis la commission est les
présidents le conseil donc la présidence
suédoise et la future présidentielle
travaille beaucoup et d'arrache-pied sur
ce sur ce sujet
c'est difficile pour moi de dire où
est-ce que quel est le point
d'atterrissage il y a beaucoup de
discussions et beaucoup de
d'avis partagé sur un certain nombre de
dispositions de ce texte
ce qui est sûr pour nous c'est que on
peut pas continuer à ne pas avoir de
position européenne sur ce sujet là donc
il nous faut avoir une position
européenne actuellement ce que je vous
évoquais sur la transmission de contenu
par nos collègues américains ça repose
sur une exception à la réglementation
européenne qui s'achèvera en août 2024
donc on a crucialement besoin si on veut
continuer à avoir des signalements
volontaires des différentes plateformes
il nous faut un texte donc ça c'est sûr
après pour le reste
je peux pas vous donner véritablement de
de détails puisque on connaît pas le
détail du texte on sait ce qui est
discuté on sait qu'elle est la
proposition initiale de la commission la
vie du Parlement est en train de
s'élaborer celui du Conseil est un peu
plus avancé mais ça nous est difficile
d'anticiper ce qui est sûr c'est que il
nous faut un texte il nous faut un texte
efficace puisque les contenus puissent
être signalés même si je voudrais aussi
relativiser parce qu'on détecte aussi
beaucoup de contenus à l'occasion de nos
enquêtes criminelles et des
investigations puisqu'en fait quand on
saisit l'ordinateur
d'un d'un criminel
on a en fait toute la collection des du
matériel et des contenus qu'il a et
c'est là où on a le plus de de matériel
ça nous permet d'ailleurs de signaler
aux plateformes des matériels qui
éventuellement seraient pas connu de de
et des contenus qui seraient pas connus
de
donc anticiper c'est c'est dans la loi
ce texte ça me paraît compliqué quand on
connaît pas le point d'arrivée
du texte qui est qui ne encore une fois
soulève beaucoup de discussions avec
certains États membres qui sont très
contre par exemple ce qu'on a browing
c'est-à-dire de réussir à monitorer les
conversations entre les les criminels
pour voir si ça change des contenus
pédophiles
enfin dernier question que vous posiez
sur les questions de protection des
données personnelles c'est évidemment un
challenge de réussir à travailler en
appliquant le rgpd et toutes les
questions de protection des données
personnelles Europol est supervisé par
le contrôleur européen de la protection
des données personnelles
il valide un certain nombre de nos
dispositifs
en particulier ceux qui concernent ces
crimes en ligne donc on est dans un
système
où on a des fortes contraintes dans ce
domaine-là mais comment ça on s'attaque
à des données personnelles évidemment on
comprend qu'on a cette contrainte qu'on
a besoin de supervision
nous ce dont on plaide ce pourquoi on
plaide c'est qu'on est une forme
d'équilibre je dirais entre la
protection des données personnelles et
la protection aussi est la sécurité de
nos concitoyens que ce soit en matière
d'infraction en ligne ou de toute autre
type d'infraction sur laquelle
évidemment les données qui sont de plus
en plus dans les mains d'opérateurs
privés peuvent être communiqués aux
forces de l'ordre dans un cadre
juridique précis avec une supervision
des magistrats évidemment et et mais il
nous faut des moyens de travailler
aujourd'hui on a pas mal de sujets qui
sont en discussion autour de ça que ce
soit le package dit évident ce que ce
soit les questions de chiffrement
etc donc la discussion est en cours
là-dessus et on n'a pas de solution
miracle
bien merci à vous dernière question qui
avait été mal je me permets de vous
reposer ma dernière question
sur la
pénalisation
où le fait de mettre en place une
sanction pénale en cas de défaut
d'exécution la demande de retrait ça
existe en matière en matière
terroriste ça existe ça va exister à
l'échelle de ce texte là en matière de
de contenu mettant en scène des enfants
est-ce que vous pensez que ça fonctionne
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est c'est
une une menace suffisamment importante
pour que elle est sur un elle entraîne
vraiment une efficacité de du retrait
des contenus
moi je pense que en tout cas c'est mieux
que rien
ça ça fait pas de doute
bon je pense que sur l'arme de quand
même la plus efficace
qui a été dans le DSA c'est évidemment
la la les amendes qui peuvent être qui
peuvent être infligées aux sociétés le
préjudice aussi réputationnel d'une
action pénale donc
[Musique]
moi je dirais que c'est
c'est positif quand même qu'on est un
moyen de coercition
pénale par le biais d'amende ou d'une
enquête pénale qu'on déclenche c'est un
moyen de négociation entre guillemets et
parfois d'action qui permet quand même
de de
à une vertu pédagogique vis-à-vis des
autres et une pédagogique vis-à-vis de
celui qui serait poursuivi donc ça vous
étonnera pas de la part d'un gendarme
que je vous dise que les une sanction
pénale et la bienvenue
merci Madame rossinet juste avant je me
tourne vers André Richard qui était
coaporteur du projet de règlement visant
à prévenir et lutter contre les abus
sexuels sur les enfants est-ce que chers
collègues vous avez une question on
regarde de ce projet de règlement
l'articulation par rapport à notre texte
de loi
pas vraiment merci madame la Présidente
c'est vrai que
toutes les questions que j'aurais posé
sur le directeur il y a déjà répondu
dans son propre polyminaire donc pour
moi c'est c'est assez clair
désolé j'ai eu un appel urgent j'étais
obligé de sortir quelques minutes donc
je ne sais pas quelle question à poser
le rapporteur ou les rapporteurs
moi ma question mais on peut la poser
ultérieurement concernait le texte le
projet de loi
qui est en discussion puisque notre
commission spéciale elle travaille sur
un projet de loi
particulier propre à notre pays et
je sais bien que vous vous n'êtes pas
législateur monsieur le directeur mais
peut-être avez-vous quand même une autre
observation à faire ou suggestions à
faire concernant ce texte si tentait que
vous en ayez bien connaissance pour ce
qui concerne vos compétences je sais pas
si cette question a déjà été déjà été
posée très bien écoutez tant pis donc
merci Madame la Président je vous en
prie je me fierai au compte-rendu merci
alors une petite question
autre rapporteur et après c'est Madame
Rossi
oui merci madame la Présidente une
question rapide Monsieur le Directeur
sur les articles qui ne sont pas suivi
par mon collègue et notamment sur le
filtre anti arnaque donc dans le projet
de loi il est prévu à la mise en place
d'un filtre entier en arc arnaque pardon
je voulais avoir votre avis sur cette
initiative
moi je pense que c'est une initiative
qui est bienvenu
le comme je vous l'ai dit les fraudes en
ligne
arnaque etc sont massives
elle touche beaucoup de nos concitoyens
c'est souvent pas des gros montants etc
voir les gens s'aperçoive en fait avant
d'être arnaqué que son étude je crois
que le travail de prévention qui est
fait là-dessus est absolument crucial
et je
j'ai le sentiment que ça progresse pour
autant les cybercriminels utilisent
encore massivement
ces moyens donc moi je pense que cette
disposition est bien venue
elle est nature à protéger les plus
vulnérables je dirais numériquement de
nos de nos concitoyens ceux qui peuvent
se laisser entre guillemets à voir
à ce genre de choses il faudra regarder
comment ça peut fonctionner
pas encore l'idée précise et c'est là où
quand j'évoquais des des
dispositions légales qui soient
résistante aux évolutions technologiques
c'est là où on a potentiellement une
difficulté parce que on peut pas dire
que demain on sera pas contourné par un
moyen ou un autre qu'on ne connaît pas
aujourd'hui ou qu'on a pas identifié
aujourd'hui mais pour répondre
brièvement je pense que c'est une bonne
disposition
qui protégera beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui sont malheureusement
victimes de ces arnaques en ligne
merci Monsieur le Directeur alors madame
Rossignol je vous souhaite la parole
pour quelques questions merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le directeur
pour votre communication je voudrais
revenir sur un propos que vous avez au
début dont j'ai à la fois je comprends
le fondement et en même temps je sur
lequel je m'interroge sur les
conséquences vous avez bien indiqué que
vous dissociez vous pédopornographie et
abus sexuel sur enfant et que vous
parlez d'abus sexuel sur enfant et non
pas de pédopornographie et vous avez
d'ailleurs dit cet instant que la
pornographie n'étant pas une infraction
pénale
j'ai compris en creux que parler de
perte de pédopornographie revient en
fait à minorer la nature enfin l'ampleur
de du crime bien sur le plan moral que
sur le plan pénal d'ailleurs
ceci dit une petite incise la
pornographie n'est pas une infraction
pénale ça se discute
ça se discute même si la pornographie
est légale faite autorisée pour autant
on pourrait
identifier dans une majeure pas la
majeure partie des contenus une
infraction pénale qui est l'incitation à
la haine l'incitation à la violence
particulier tout ce qui concerne
l'incitation au viol par l'apologie du
viol ou également l'incitation à
l'inceste sert une incitation aux abus
sexuels sur enfants mais je ferme cette
parenthèse parce que pour un monde on
n'est pas encore tout à fait là mais je
m'interroge et sur le fait que en
réalité en ne retenant que les abus
sexuels sur enfants
je crains que ça limite le champ de
votre intervention parce que vous
recherchez dans chaque contenu
pornographique le fait que un enfant a
bien été abusé pour tourner mettre en
image ce qui ce qui est montré
quand on interroge farros sur les
critères puisque les Pharaons regarde
images par image qui est un petit
problème quand même un gros problème
pour pour nous parce que les contenus
regardez images par image pour
identifier si la personne victime d'abus
sexuel et bien ou non un enfant puisque
vous savez parieur que la loi dit
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit prouvé que il
avait plus de 18 ans et quand on demande
à Pharos quel est le critère qui a
retenu par farose pour identifier est-ce
que c'est un enfant un mineur c'est
moins de 18 ans ou non
farose a répondu nous on s'en tient au
critère de RuPaul donc c'est vous qui
apparemment définissez des critères pour
savoir si l'image est bien celle d'un
majeur ou d'un mineur or j'ai entendu
élu par ailleurs que dans une autre
audition Pharos a reconnu ou admis que
il entraînait des critères d'apparence
cette apparence étant les signes
extérieurs de puberté en l'occurrence
pour des poils et des seins or vous
savez que on a des poils et des dessins
bien avant 18 ans c'est-à-dire qu'on est
un enfant avec des poils et des seins
jusqu'à 18 ans donc ça restreint le
champ d'intervention là-dessus et puis
la deuxième chose c'est que à ne pas
parler de pédopornographie a préféré la
pédocriminalité le deuxième risque est
que on ne recherche pas et on ne vise
pas à faire retirer les images qui ont
l'intention de représenter de la
sexualité enfantine et d'un certain
point de vue peu importe que la personne
filmée et ou non 18 ans ce qui compte
c'est qu'on a voulu avec cette image
banaliser la sexualité des enfants et
des rapports sexuels entre des enfants
et des adultes donc est-ce que vous
craignez pas à la fois que la définition
que vous faites entre
pornographie pédocriminalité limite
votre champ d'intervention et
deuxièmement est-ce que vous nous
confirmez que est pour la traque des
images très compliquée je suis pleine de
compassion d'admiration bon travail qui
fait par les enquêteurs sur ces vidéos
mais le critère retenu ne permet pas ne
permettent pas d'identifier des
infractions sur commisses sur des
mineurs pourvu de poils et de ça
la parole suite à la question de notre
collègue Laurence Rossignol oui merci
de cette question
enfin nous on établit pas des critères
formellement si vous voulez
il y a tout un tas de matériel ou c'est
absolument évident et où il y a aucune
discussion sur le fait que on a affaire
à des enfants
donc tous ces
toutes ces images là en fait vont être
transmises aux autorités nationales
parce que ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que les poursuites ne sont pas
décidées par Europole et poursuites sont
décidés par des magistrats qui à la
lecture de compte-rendu d'enquêteurs au
visionnage de certaines images peuvent
déterminer qu'il y a ou pas infraction
les poursuites sont pas dans les
des policiers ou des gendarmes mais
elles sont bien dans les mains des
magistrats nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est détecter les les choses qui sont
absolument
évidentes de la même façon que si vous
avez des scènes de violence qui peuvent
se positionner qui peuvent avoir être
visuel comment dire visionner entre
adultes un moment on peut être sur des
coûts et blessures sur d'autres
infractions que vous avez évoquées mais
on n'est plus là dans le domaine des
abus sexuels sur les enfants on est dans
un autre domaine qui peut être
l'exploitation des
êtres humains qui peut être le
proxénétisme qui peut être tout un tas
d'autres infractions donc c'est pas
notre seul point d'entrée je dirais et
donc
les critères de repos c'est d'ailleurs
des critères qui sont partagés avec
Interpol et avec toute la communauté
puisque c'est une communauté
d'enquêteurs qui travaillent beaucoup
ensemble et de magistrats
qui travaillent ensemble pour définir ça
tout ce qui est complètement évident on
le traite ce qui là où on n'est pas sûr
et où il y a une marge mais quand on a
un doute suffisamment sérieux soit que
on a affaire à un enfant doté comme vous
le dites après la puberté
mais qui reste un enfant dans va
transmettre le signalement aux autorités
nationales et c'est elle qui vont
décider si il y a lieu ou pas de
démarrer une enquête ou d'investigation
à condition qu'on est des éléments pour
déterminer où ça se passe etc ce qui est
ce qui est un de nos sujets
essentiel et puis si on constate sur des
du matériel mais c'est pas celui qu'on
recherche de de pornographie où il y a
des faits de violence
qui sont commis entre adultes ou par des
adultes visiblement contraints à ce
moment-là ça rentre dans un autre champ
législatif qui est pas celui de la
bussexualité sur les enfants mais qui
peut être celui des violences commises à
une personne vulnérable ou la traite
comme je le disais la traite des êtres
humains etc donc
pour et j'espère que j'ai répondu à
votre question on a nous une vision qui
est d'ailleurs
multidirectionnelle en matière
d'infraction et sur lesquels je dirais
ses limites c'est pas nous qui les
fictions mais on va en référer toujours
à l'autorité nationale où il y a des
autorités de poursuite procureurs en
fonction des systèmes juridiques en
fonction aussi des réglementations
nationales parce que les réglementations
nationales ne sont pas les mêmes en
France en Allemagne en Lituanie ou ou en
République tchèque donc on va utiliser
aussi c'est c'est réglementations
nationales et c'est après si vous
autorités nationales de décider s'il y a
lieu de démarrer ou pas des
investigations qu'on pourra nous ensuite
appuyer par la suite par nos moyens
bien merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur je tourne à mes collègues
est-ce qu'il y a encore quelques
questions
voilà qui se pose non je n'en vois pas
ben écoutez
au nom des rapporteurs et des membres de
notre commission spéciale je voulais
vous remercier beaucoup pour vous êtes
mis à disposition voilà des travaux de
notre commission encore une fois merci
beaucoup aussi pour tout ce que vous
faites j'ai commencé mon propos en
disant que j'avais l'occasion la chance
de pouvoir visiter le site de repos à
l'AS qui m'a frappé c'est la très bonne
coordination entre les États membres
représentés et même au-delà puisque il y
a des représentants bien au-delà de
l'Europe et je pense que c'est une
excellente chose j'avais entendu parler
de de ce réseau appelé boystown je crois
que vous avez réussi à démanteler qui
concernait des milliers et des milliers
de personnes et donc on vous souhaite
vraiment de bien réussir parce qu'on a
besoin de vous pour poursuivre ce
travail de longue haleine voilà merci
infiniment Monsieur le Directeur
merci à vous